Do you remember could you describe me the first fossil you found. The first fossil
I found was found behind apartment building where I lived when I was about eleven years old
and I was interested in natural history in this period of my life I was a big reader of books about nature animals
plants butterflies all sorts of things like that and.
I had the chance to visit the Natural History Museum in Paris with my cousin.
And my cousin offered me a little book about fossils and I was very enthusiastic about finding fossils myself.
And so using this little book I scouted around the house in the neighborhood and luckily
Well by the way nothing very surprising.
I found a mollusc on a piece of lime stone and so I was happy to connect that with what I had in this book
and that was my first fossil really what you were twelve years old something like that when you found it? Eleven
and what did you find so fascinating of this fossile. Well it's a complicated story.
I was born in Algeria and I grew up there until I was like eight years old.
And I grew up in a very I would say unstable
and violent environment because it was a colonial war there a colonial war that turned to be a civilian war
in the end. And so my my childhood was surrounded by a very I would say scary environment somehow.
And then I was deported outside of the country with my family
and I lived in France around Paris in not so nice neighborhoods for some years. And I think probably to me.
Natural history was a sort of escape into a world that was much nicer somehow in this rather grim or scary environment
and I when I discovered paleontology when I discovered fossils.
In this natural history museum I realize that beyond the nature of today there was another nature.
There were ancient natures and it was like a multiplication of this world
and it was even more fascinating because we did not know everything about these past worlds
and there was a lot to discover.
So that's where it started. When you went on looking into the fossils what you find or discover.
Well I was I think I was a little bit obsessed by fossils. In this time period of my life and so.
I had the chance at the middle school where I was to meet a professor who was also interested in fossils
and paleontology and supported me and pushed me to persevere in this topic
and so I had a lot of activities that were either at school or with this professor and that was around paleontology.
We created a local geology club and we did a lot of excursions to find fossils with other kids.
I know I was the most motivated of all of them I was the president of the association
and the chief editor of the journal the probably the only reader of the journal and then yeah.
So basically I think at this stage of my life I decided what I wanted to be what I wanted to do
and I just continued throughout the years to work in this direction and I never really.
Deviated much. still what is so fascinating for you now at this age about it. Well I yeah.
Now it becomes something a little bit different.
I would say because now I'm mostly interested about human fossils and not just reconstructing nature and environment
but I'm working on humans who lived a long time before us
and these Humans are not exactly like us they share a lot of features they somehow belong to human kind but
but they are also different in many aspects and so they are a little bit like to say aliens somehow
and I found this extremely fascinating to think on humans which are not completely humans like us. the other thing is
and this also probably connects with my childhood.
I think there is something about saving something from death and oblivion
and the fate of all living creatures is to disappear completely. But by chance when we have a fossil of a human.
who lived half a million year ago.
So suddenly we saved something of this life somehow we we  resuscitate a part of his existence
and we can learn things about even his or her daily life. So to me it's not just a piece of bone.
somehow it's a person.
And of course I would say the communication is very limited with this person but there is something like that.
So it's a bit like travelling through time and connecting with a lost world.
And discovering things that are somehow unknown to others
or unknown to us until we are able to unveil something of their past reality. and what kind of humans.
what are we talking about. Well today we live in a world where there is only one kind of humans.
And we have we are what we call what paleontologists and biologists call modern humans and modern humans are.
a late version of a species that we call homo sapiens and today this is the only species of humans on Earth but
when we move back in time. It was almost never like that.
So in past there was
always several groups of humans we don't know if we should call them specious or subspecies
but what is clear is that we had groups of humans in the past that were much more different one from the other than any
kind of differences that you can see today between modern humans living in different parts of the world so.
An order of magnitude higher and so just moving let's say a hundred thousand years ago.
We know that we have the ancestor of modern humans living in Africa.
But on other continents we have Neanderthals in Europe
and parts of Asia is a group living in the Far East that we call Denisovans and it's a group that has been identified
rather recently we also know that in some islands off Indonesia like Flores we have another kind of
creature which is probably the descendants of local homo erectus a very ancient hominin
and these humans living in Flores they are very minute creatures. They are being called Hobbits.
And all these groups they are there are quite different one from the other
what happened at some point is that our ancestors the modern humans who lived in Africa started to expand outside
of their geographical domain. And they expanded first in Southwest Asia.
Maybe they entered a large portion of Asia rather early
and then about I would say fifty thousand years ago their expansion accelerated a lot
and so they started moving into the domain of the Neanderthals in Europe they went to Australia they moved
further east in the place where the Denisovans lived.
Eventually they entered in the higher latitudes they passed in the Americas.
via the Bering strait and they went to all the most remote islands in the middle of oceans.
What made them or us actually, our ancestors so successful.
That's a big mystery actually that's the question we try to understand to resolve.
and what's in what's fascinating
when one compares modern humans Neanderthals other hominins of the time period around Say hundred to fifty thousand
years ago that we see that all these hominins are sort of evolving in the same direction and they have bigger
and bigger brains and they have more and more complex behaviors
and probably they are sort of responding to the same kind of pressure of selection.
But something happened with one of these groups our ancestors that gradually made them I would say extremely successful
as a species and
when we say successful for a species it means that these species have a higher reproductive success than others. And so.
These humans start to replace all the others.
We know now that there was a certain level of admixture with local population and that's an idea that the.
The media and the public like very much. But the truth is that this admixture was very reduced in fact very little.
A couple of percent not more. And so it's primarily a replacement of population.
So there is something with our species which is new. At the scale of hominin evolution.
And this something new.
Could be related to technology for example people some people have believed that these modern humans had some kind of
new tools new weapons some kind of new cognitive abilities. Maybe something related to the complexity of
Language for example or it could also be something related to.
The complexity of the social networks of these people. in what way. Well.
Humans are extremely good at creating connections with other humans and not just humans in their direct
environment but even humans living far away. And so.
So in other words the
when we speak about a group of humans we don't speak about families we talk about networks that covers a very large
portion of a continent.
And so we don't know exactly when this developed in the course of human evolution but it's very likely that.
Belonging to such a large network is a considerable strength.
If you compete with other hominins who are basically organized in the form of local groups which can be very
successful but with the size of the social network more result. This is one idea but there are many others.
There are also many I would say psychological traits of modern humans which of course are very difficult to investigate
in the fossil record but things like if you think on things like altruism or heroism
or things like that it's you know the ability of a individual to lose something for the benefit of others
or even to sacrifice himself for a self for the survival of others. This also. It's a remarkable feature of humans.
Again we don't know exactly when in the course of human evolution these develop but we can easily imagine that.
One group having this kind of behaviors that would compete with another group that does not have this kind of
features. Well that would be also a big advantage. and not so nice for the competition I suppose.
Yeah but of course today we.
We like to think on humans of the past with I would say with pink glasses and so we like to think on
hunter gatherers of the past Neanderthals or early modern humans as peaceful
hunter gatherers that lived in equilibrium with nature and did not overexploit the environment and were nice.
With others. I'm not so convinced that humans have ever been so good.
Again I think maybe it's a memory of my own childhood or life but I know that humans can be.
really terrible with others especially others from a different group
and so you can love your family your children your friends your neighbors and.
And kill other people who have a different language
or a different kind of culture. so in a way humans are dangerous as a species for other species.
Well humans. actually humans have been dangerous not just for other humans
but they have been dangerous in general for other species
and there is something that could be related to the expansion of modern humans. Showing that.
Let's say after fifty thousand we see signs of a direct impact of the human expansion.
On the environment
and especially on the fauna of course there are already signs of that further back in the past we see for
example when humans start to hunt.
Other animals they compete with carnivores and in this competition sometimes carnivores are very good
but sometimes humans are better.
So we have reduction of the number of carnivores in Africa already between two and one million years ago but
when modern humans started to expand out of Africa especially
when they're going to reach areas where humans never lived before places where there was no Neanderthals no Denisovan
nothing places like Australia for example or Americas.
So there the impact of these groups is going to be rather terrible on the on the fauna
we see a lot of large animals disappearing
and we think that the predation of humans is for something so. and what is it that makes it so dangerous.
Well I think probably the difference between modern humans recent modern humans.
And other hominins is that we have a way to exploit the resource which is much more intense somehow For example we know
that Neanderthals in Europe co-existed with a number of species that are going to disappear
when modern humans arrived and replaced Neanderthals.
By the way in a rather provocative way I could say Neanderthals were just like another species of predators that has
been eliminated by modern humans I know it's politically incorrect. How did we do that. Well for the fauna
It's quite easy to understand it it looks like the number of preys that we extract from the environment is for some
species is too high.
Very large animals like say elephants for example they have a rather slow reproduction rate
and so if you start taking too many young individuals at some point it becomes not sustainable for the species
carnivores Well you can hunt them directly.
You can also compete with them for the preys and then the result is more or less the same.
Now for humans it's difficult to say because you have many ways one group of humans can replace another
and I think in the case of Neanderthals. We have a competition for the occupation of the European territory.
Between Neanderthals and modern humans.
I don't think these groups they co-existed anywhere for a long time I think at the scale of the continents they co-existed
but locally in one region one valley. I don't think so and so you can you can have a direct.
I would say conflict.
You know hunter gatherers off to I mean recent
hunter gatherers they they go at war against other groups especially when they compete for a resource.
So you know you kill the men you take the women you do things not very nice
but then of course there are other factors that can add on that you can be more.
effective in exploiting the environment which means in the end you're going to have more children
and these children have a higher chance of survival
and you can have also a long higher longevity higher chance of survival as a young adult all these put together
especially if you're dealing with groups that are represented by small numbers
and this is something we it's difficult to imagine for us but
when we speak about early modern humans or Neanderthals in Europe we're talking about population size of
ten thousand twenty thousand something like that maybe a bit more
but not we're not talking about hundreds of thousands or millions.
So for groups of a I would say a few thousand individual if you have a difference in demographic success clearly one's
going to replace another and then you have other things like disease Things like that so.
Finally it's a it's a complex process including absorption of some individuals in the group
but in the end what is clear is that.
Let's say after forty thousand years ago in in Europe in most of Europe you have only modern humans maybe there are
some Neanderthals surviving in a corner in the southern Iberia our places like that but not for a very long time.
And if you look at the genome of these Modern humans in Europe in this time period.
We have something like about four percent of Neanderthal D.N.A.
In their genome and this four percent are going to gradually decrease because there is a selection
a natural selection against this part of the genome and today.
non African humans carry about two percent of Neanderthal genome  and we're not sure that in this two percent
there are much D.N.A.
Coding for important features which is another aspect of the problem. And why did you choose
To to go in this scientific field I mean looking into humans and not in other species. Why did you choose that. Well.
Well first of all I continued to be interested in other creatures than than humans.
But what I like with human evolution is that it allowed me to combine also an interest for archaeology.
And archaeology is the science investigating the material culture of humans
and trying to understand what is going on in terms of technical evolution or other behaviors for humans
and what is really peculiar with hominins in general
and especially more with modern humans is that it's impossible to disentangle cultural evolution
and biological evolution and so the the whole story of human evolution is an interaction between culture.
And social organization and biology and looking at one without looking at the other is sort of.
I would say meaningless. And what makes you and your institute so incredibly good at this. Well For me I guess it's motivation
Like for everything
in life you have to be very motivated in what you do what I've tried to do
when I moved to Leipzig was to create a department where there was these different aspects of human evolution that
could be investigated and not just with I would say.
Classical methods of human paleontology and paleolithic archaeology.
But putting
also on top of that many methods coming from what is called archaeological sciences which basically means physics
and chemistry applied to the kind of questions we can address. For human evolution and so this
This concept is something that I did not really invent myself because there are other people who had this idea that
basically we had to look at all these aspects of human evolution
but as a matter of fact there are very few places on earth.
If there are any beside here in Leipzig where all these aspects are studied. By one department.
Going into all these directions. When I was a young scientist I.
I was invited to teach at Berkeley University where there was a professor who was just getting retired.
Francis Clark Howell
and Francis Clark Howell had a very strong influence on me. he was the one who basically proposed this concept
of what is called paleoanthropology.
Which is putting together all sort of fields including things like environmental sciences paleoclimatology.
looking at many other aspects of the surroundings of hominins to try to decipher human evolution.
And Clark I would say developed his career in a academic environment in the U.S. where there was still a department of anthropology
Where there was for example cultural anthropology and palaeontology together and with other things like linguistics
or genetics all these in one big department today this is gone.
Mostly. And now it's only here in Leipzig. it's not only here but it's mostly here
and so I was I was extremely I would say fortunate to be offered to create this department in this institute because
this institute already addresses the question of what makes humans different. And to address this question.
There were already in this institute departments like linguistics genetics primatology the study of our
direct relatives African apes and Asian apes people also working on
The development of psychology in children and apes
and to me I thought it looked to me like that was like the best place to develop my department with people coming
with these different disciplines.
And with the modern techniques of course you are able to discover and understand more
and more of this human evolution. We become much more ambitious today yeah. In the.
When I started to do paleontology when I was let's say this little boy looking for fossils or even when I was a student
and doing my Ph D.
Studying the fossils were mostly looking at bumps and holes on bones and making measurements
and trying to describe the shape of different fossils and basically grouping them in different species
and trying to built up a tree of human evolution and connecting that with a chronology and some stone artefacts
but today we try to investigate things like diet like mobility. Accessing the genome of fossils.
It's something we even did not think of when I was a beginner in the field
and now we can say things about you know how connected were the father
and the mother of a Neanderthal who lived forty five thousand years ago and we can say oh this pair the mother
and the father they could have been maybe half siblings or cousins
or things like that we can say things about the mobility of humans in the landscape.
We can say even things about the way they exploit the fauna
what kind of if the animals they are hunting are coming from far away
or they are local animals so we can really say a lot of things about I would say their daily life.
In the meantime of course there is a sort of frustrating limit. That seems still impossible.
Sometime I ask what would you like to know.
About Neanderthals for example
and as a joke a couple of time I already said Oh I would like to know what kind of relationship
a Neanderthal had with his brother in law.
And I think yeah this is really where it would be really important for example to figure out what could have been a
difference between Neanderthals and modern humans. I'm not sure we know that ever. But it is a limit that
You would like to cross. Yeah sure sure.
I think there is a difficulty in our field and the difficulty comes from the fact that it's a paradox
but there is a great interest of the public for Origins. people want to know about origins they want to know about
Neanderthals and modern humans
and it's incredibly popular. somehow it's great because I guess this is how I could make a job of these interest in the
meantime it results in the construction of mythology I would say that is a sort of scientific mythology.
That replaced a religious believe in the past. So all human societies have their myth of origin.
Western societies they have prehistory and paleoanthropology
and so the result of that is that there is a lot of storytelling for basically to compensate for the lack of
information we have with many aspects of the nature and the life of ancient humans.
And so we tend to. There is a sort of pressure of the environment the public the media for us to tell stories.
And so there are many topics for which we have to use our imagination to basically fill the gaps
and so this is where it's a bit problematic because I think we fill the gap with conceptions that are mostly depending
on the ideology of the historical period where we live.
And so I always warn the students about even scientific papers about separating the evidence.
The scientific results and the storytelling and there is always a little bit of storytelling.
What kind of storytelling should i think about. Oh I it's quite obvious that for example this question of
The difference between Neanderthals and modern humans or the replacement process of Neanderthals by modern humans
and things like that are deeply influenced by scenarios that we have in mind.
And which are not always just a deduction from the empirical evidence that we have from sites. And if you.
For example if you like to think that ancient hunter gatherers was you know.
As I said peaceful hunter gatherers who were preoccupied by ecology
and not discriminating these poor Neanderthals you are going to built up stories around that.
And so I think our field is easily filled with this kind of thing. And as you move further back in time.
I think we have a fundamental misunderstanding of what ancient hominins were because the natural trend for humans is to
project themselves in the past. So when we speak about hominins living a million and a half years ago.
Rather naturally we see them as humans of today that would not have all the technology that we have.
And maybe a smaller brain
but basically it would be very close to us they would be in better health a bit stronger
but they would see the world like we see it and they would see each other as we see each other
and I think this is completely wrong in fact but.
For millennia humans they have built up this vision of the world where they are there is us
and the rest of the world for example we see us as completely separated from animals.
When in fact if you look at many of the human features that have been for a long time believed to be proper to humans.
You will find out that you find all these things in many other species of course not with the degree of complexity or
the degree of intensity that you see in humans but you will find it so in other words.
There is not a very well cut limit between the humans and the others.
And so there is this grey zone where we have archaic hominins which I think to me again I found it absolutely fascinating.
But for many people including in my field of science. Yeah there is this.
Sort of tendency to separate what is the real humans and something more much more different and primitive before.
And so we in other words which we have a tendency to humanize as much as possible.
Everything which is close to us in time
and then beyond a certain point then we basically see everything like very primitive very different.
And so this border has been moving through time and so.
For some people humans start with the genius homo for other the humans start with modern humans
and you have almost everything in between and of course the reality is much more complex. There is a sentence in.
A book by a famous French writer called Toqueville who wrote a book about.
Democracy in America and in this book Toqueville says somewhere that any wrong idea
but that would be very simple and very clear would be always much more successful than a complicated but true
Concept and I think it is very true also in science and in my science especially. It's also actually when you think about that.
It's what we can learn from your scientific field can help us also to understand what will happen to the human species
in the future. I think yes. Somehow you can see the field of human evolution like a sort of substitute for.
A mythology a myth of origin and it's of course it's a science but it has this mythological dimension
also but recently I think there is another
sort of aspect that has been developing a lot which is trying to understand.
The way humans evolved in the past and the way humans interacted with other species and with the planet in general.
Give us a sort of deeper perspective on what could be the future of human evolution and.
And this is a rather new I would say preoccupation for humans.
Humans have been always preoccupied by what was going to happen in the future.
But for example the notion that humans are changing the climate.
The notion that humans are pushing to extinction so many species something rather new.
At the scale of human evolution I would say. So it's really a historical process that is just very close to us.
So many people worry about the fact that since the global warming has been discovered we don't do much.
Well as a matter of fact if you. again if you think on deep history
I found remarkable that so soon after finding out something is going on that we are already trying to find
a solution and somehow I'm rather optimistic I think humans will find solutions and try to change that but
but again to sort of have an influence of this interaction between humans and environment is very important to.
to have the background to understand what was before and how humans have already altered the planet.
There is another aspect which is the biological and even social evolution of humans.
There are many practical things like for example our diet.
You know the way we eat we feed our bodies it's something today that become.
Is becoming a problem for a lot of obese people. why. Well there is a evolutionary
Explanation for that we have adaptations that were designed somehow for a different style of life.
And so the fact that humans have developed very peculiar features in the past to be successful is very important to
figure out why we are where we are today. And even going deeper into for example.
Questions that now become really I would say dramatically important like acting on our own genome.
Again it's dramatically important to understand what has been the past evolution of humans
and what you know how selection worked on humans
and why humans are what they are before we started to play with our own genes. It's a new chapter of life.
Evolution starting because it never happened before that one species living species could take the control of the
genome of other species.
To this extent in a sort of deliberate way
and then started to somehow take the control of its own genome.
But that made also the human species so successful that we were always able to.
Yeah but I would say we are successful and dangerous
and it's because we are dangerous that we have been successful somehow. But now we have to be careful with.
This notion of danger and success because maybe there is a level of danger that ultimately would hurt our success.
So in the. In other words we have to think a lot on and I think we do it.
Actually I think I found it somehow admirable somehow of course we don't do it as much as we should
but at least there are people doing it.
Again if you think on the past history of humans for the last millennia.
It's something really new somehow. and we create new species technical species.
Yeah we oh you know something really amazing.
There are many things amazing about human evolution
but there is one thing that I like to think of is the way humans have externalised biological function.
In their technical or social environment. And there would be we could speak for hours about this but.
This is really something fascinating and by the way it explains why cultural
and social evolution is so basically intertwined with the biological evolution. And humans have this very peculiar.
niche in nature that they create.
complex societies they create artefacts they have this trend to more and more behavioral complexity
and to do that they need a big brain and not just a big brain but a very good big brain
and this big brain is fantastic. We can do amazing things with with our brain. No need to detail that.
But this big brain has a cost. And the cost is very high. It is very high in terms of energy supply.
It's very high in terms of maintenance
and all sort of things it has a very high price in terms of producing other humans babies and children etc.
And so we had to change a lot of things. In our biology. To accommodate this very costly organ.
And
when we say we had to change it isn't It was not a deliberate decision of humans it's natural selection that pushed
us into this direction
and so we have reorganized a lot of things in our biology physiology to make this possible this evolution things like
our diet. Again the way we reproduce things like that in the meantime.
This has been made possible because of the technical environment that we created. If you think for example on diet.
We can extract much more calories from our food to fuel our costly brain because we have weapons that in the past
were used to kill animals at a distance we had tools to dispatch the carcasses of these animals we were able to.
Later we have learned how to cook food to prepare the food we eat etc
and so in other words things that were basically
handled by our organism in the past had been delegated to things which are external to our body
and this is true for other aspects.
Not just in the technical or material domain but also in the social domain like for example.
The brain is very costly for an adult is even more costly for a child. And it's a big issue.
If you think on that for a mother to be able to fuel and maintain their own brain
and in the meantime to develop a baby with a brain that is also very costly
and so we gradually we started to have a very peculiar way to give birth to children
and we gave birth to children with a brain which is unfinished. I mean all.
I mean for most mammals the brain isn't finished at birth.
But our brain is really unfinished and so most of the growth of the brain occures.
After birth especially the wiring of the brain and so this wiring develops
when you are interacting with the environment which by the way makes it even more efficient
and complex a little bit like you would.
Remodel a computer that you would be using for different tasks you know
but then there is another sort of layer on that is that by weaning our children very early and making them.
able to eat solid food before their brain became.
Too big it became possible for the females to share the burden of fueling the brain of the developing children with other
adults of the group. So we became co-operative breeders and so the you know the.
Raising children is a collective venture.
For humans. But now we're also able to externalize the brain we make artificial brain. Exactly.
So now we continue to externalize we externalize memory and this started already with coding things.
The writing is already.
I mean just representing pictures symbols was already a way to externalize something out of our brain then a second
major step was writing because then writing was you know you could store as many as almost as much as information
you wanted without having to hold it in your brain. You know when when writing was invented.
There were people and still the ancient Greeks
or the druids in Europe worried about writing because they had this feeling that people would lose their ability to
remember things because they had this easy way to record things. I mean ancient Greeks some ancient Greeks.
But now of course we go much further with digital storage of information
and by the way extending this I mentioned already this ability and this need of humans for building up networks.
Now these networks are planetary networks and again it's through technology that we have been able to do that.
But I think the following step would be a sort of reinternalization of what we have as externalized as devices.
So in other words. Well this is a bit of science fiction but people worry a lot about.
Intelligent machines robots basically competition between humans and artificial intelligence.
I think we will internalize artificial intelligence so it would not be any more external
but internal somehow and people have tried already to implant.
Chips electronic chips in part of the brain of animals and there are some attempts with humans also.
So I don't know if it will be about.
Memory but it could be for other functions and basically we are very far from being cyborgs but I think.
The notion that we can sort of enhance
Some human capabilities in an artificial way it's on the table and it's something which is more and more considered
and I think it will be together with altering our genome
and the way we interact with the environment the genome of other creatures.
These are big ethical issues for humans not for the future for today and
and again I think it's dramatically important to have a perspective about where we come from.
And why we are here to basically be able to handle these questions.
Many of these questions that today are discussed like if you think on that like for example artificial procreation or the.
You know basically externalizing reproduction.
People think it's something completely you know crazy
and something that develops in post modern societies with people doing sort of crazy experiences.
Experiments and things like that. As a paleoanthropologist I have a different view.
I think it's just a continuation of things we have been doing for a long time already in the course of our evolution
ofcourse it is very spectacular it is very extreme but somehow if you if you think on that especially regarding reproduction.
Our reproduction as modern humans has been made possible because we created an artificial environment around
reproduction and when I say we created an artificial environment.
I'm not talking about medical progress in the twentieth century.
I'm talking about paleolithic times but basically the way.
I mean the possibility to have these so immature neonates
Surviving and developing all these cognitive skills and being maintained for twenty years before they become adults
and reproduce and be part of the society has been made possible only because with our big brain.
We created a technical environment and a social environment for that.
And so again what we see in modern societies is just like the continuation of this trend.
Now of course it's up to us to decide what is good or bad and how far I mean when I say good or bad.
I'm not talking about religious belief
but I'm talking about what is what could be counterproductive for us as a species. Could you tell me what are
the questions.
You are looking for answers for. The field I address has many questions and this is due to the fact that hominin
evolution covers several millions of years and we have a whole variety of species that existed during this time period
and there is one thing that is important to realize is that we know only a portion
and maybe only a small portion of these groups of hominins that existed in the past there are time periods
and regions for which we have no information at all
and that does not mean that there was nothing there just means we don't know.
So basically we have a pile of cut branches and we try to build a tree but we don't have all the branches
and so somehow the tree we build is not so accurate that we think it is. So that's one part of the story.
which is basically looking for fossils finding new hominins and completing this big puzzle.
Again remember that out of this complex bush today there is just one.
Branch that sticks out and gave birth to all species.
So beside that there are many questions about What are humans and how different they are from other creatures.
So in other words we have.
A part of the field which is not really looking at the past but is more looking at humans of.
Today and analyzing for example the differences that we can detect or study between apes
and humans we know that African apes and especially chimpanzees are very closely related to us.
And so somehow studying living primates is very important also and then after we identify
some key aspects of humans for example things about their of course their anatomy their big
brain. Their reduced .. things like that their diet. But also aspects of their social organization. Reproductive pattern
development pattern. psychology.
So then the game is to go into this tree that is I remind you an incomplete tree
and try to find out when these different features develop and why and how along these different branches
and what's emerging today is this picture that in fact all these branches somehow achieved a certain kind of humankind
somehow. But not completely like us and so they have some of these features not others.
And we are just at the beginning of understanding that and trying to decipher the complexity of this evolution
and recently what happened in the field is that we had a very fast development of paleogenetic studies.
And there is this other way to look at the past which is I would say a molecular way. Through D.N.A.
Also through ancient proteins now people study proteins and try to make philogeny
and all this molecular information provides us with all sorts of other
Information but also many new questions that we never envisioned before. What kind of questions.
Well so far paleogenetics has been mostly dealing with.
What we call philogeny which is basically the construction of the tree.
So how one group is related to another when was there a split point in the past.
Information about the demography were these groups large or small Did they suffer
demographic crashes bottlenecks for example.
And then we have discovered that the level of admixture between all these groups is more is higher
and more consistent than we think it was. Actually this is nothing proper to humans. Now that we are able to do.
High resolution sequencing of many many creatures we see that the history of species is intermixing a little bit.
It's common. it exists among primates among elephants among horses among carnivores everywhere.
Basically all species that were not separated for more than say five million years they can more
or less interbreed. There is one thing that paleogenetics and genetics.
So far it is not really able to address or start to question is what we call phenotypic expression.
So in other words when we find a difference in the genome.
What does it mean in terms of features. is it something. first of all we know that some differences have no
effect on the phenotype So it's nothing we can detect as a difference. in the meantime sometimes a small difference can
result in a major effect in the phenotype so among three billions and a half of nucleotides in D.N.A.
We know that some mutation that just changes one out of more than three billions can have a dramatic effect on how one
individual looks like
and so we are now at a stage where we know that a certain number of coding genes that are present in all modern
humans are absent in Neanderthals or other archaic humans
and conversely there are some versions of some genes which are not found in modern humans
but only on the Neanderthal What does it mean in terms of anatomy biology behavior our brain development whatever we don't
we don't know it's always frustrating
when you ask geneticists Oh you find this gene so what does it mean in general they say we don't know.
And we are. that's a field that is also developing now. people are trying to find ways to resolve that.
And there is a lot of work so I think they are going to manage in the near future to bring some questions.
Some answers. It's a great time to be what you are. Yes when I was when I was a Ph D student.
I was a bit depressed I mean that's probably the normal destiny  of a Ph D.
Student I guess. but I had this feeling that I was born too late in a world too old
and that many issues about what I was interested in: Neanderthals homo erectus homo sapiens etc.
has been already investigated by very bright scientists. I could not be more wrong than that because in fact.
First of all.
Since I was a student there is a number of new groups of hominin that has been found. incredible. Second
There are many aspects of biology and behavior
of ancient hominins that we could not conceive to be accessible to scientific investigation.
So the methodologies been developing at an incredible speed.
So in other words what I'm saying is that probably I witness more progresses in my field since I was a student until
today than probably in the previous half century.
So I think it's a very exciting time
and I don't think there is reasons why this would stop you know I tell the young students scientist I say you know.
It's going to continue.
And of course there are some issues with the development of all these new methodologies because sometimes they are very
costly or very sophisticated even at a personal level they demand.
A lot of investment from the scientists in the way that in order to master these methodologies you have to
become very specialized. sometimes I fear that we are going to miss.
People who are more generally somehow. I see myself as a as a generalist it was always my problem.
I was interested in too many things varied.
Somehow it was a great chance that I was given this possibility to build up a department where I can
I can hire people who do all the things I will never do because I cannot do
Everything. But basically delegating all these projects to other people.
But again I think it's always important when you do science and when you study
and you are very good very expert in a narrow field. You can be the best.
But it is very important to step back and know understand.
What is the big picture and where your little piece of the puzzle fits into this big picture.
What are you afraid of. nothing.
You mean for my field for in general. is there something you can lay awake in bed about.
Not much in fact. Of course I am anxious about details I would say. Sometime we have a paper we want to publish.
It's very important to us and it fails for some reason yeah it's stressing
it's vexing. Or there are projects we would like to do and it does not work sometimes for.
I would say political reasons.
In the broad sense. interaction with others competition with other groups but
but in general these issues are much more I would say problematic for young scientists starting in the field.
For me I would say I suffer for them. But I don't take it personally too much at heart.
In fact the only thing I fear is not working anymore. Basically getting retired and not being able to.
To do what I'm doing every day and I think this is not a very original fear.
But I think it's a fear that many scientists have and.
Clearly the day I won't have any more capability to develop all these projects to follow them to support students
or young scientist.
It's a great thing to be able to work every day with young people who have a lot of great ideas and basically to say well.
Let's do it and help them to do it.
So yeah this day yeah I fear it a little bit. During history
Paleoanthropology has been misused also as a.
Particularly idealistically. Sorry. Through ideologies. Yeah from an ideological point. How do you see that.
Yeah I think the field is strongly influenced by the ideology of the time 'Zeitgeist' or also by the
Sometimes by political power by I would say nationalism for example.
So there are many stories about how people have been biased in the way they interpreted the archaeological evidence
in particular based on nationalist issues and so.
I would say rarely I mean speaking about paleolithical archeology it is not true for archaeology of more recent periods
but speaking about paleolithic archeology. There are a few examples where we can say there is a major misuse of the field.
I see more this as a I would say a pollution of the scientific speech by conceptions which are nonscientific.
And I think we have to live with that somehow we have to accept it we have to
but the way to live with that is to be aware of this.
I think a common mistake today is to think that this was true in the nineteenth century or the.
The beginning of the twentieth century but that today you know we we are.
Good scientists and we are freed from all these things. I think we are not more free today than we were a century ago
and I see that every day. In what way do you see that. Well I see that there are I would say there are fashions. In the field.
Even for example the way hominins are represented.
We are often asked to provide pictures of this ancient world and we easily make fun of the reconstructions that were made a century ago.
Somehow I think our representations today are also sort of funny. If you go to the Neanderthal museum.
In .. or near Dusseldorf they have a reconstruction of a Neanderthal with a suit and a tie.
Which is watching at the visitors.
I think this is the expression of a conception that we have today of how we want to think of the Neanderthals like
other humans just like modern humans almost.
But I think it's as wrong as the representation of a Neanderthal like a gorilla that escaped from a zoo. I think so.
We sort of add on this material I would say a philosophical or ideological conception that we have today.
Now what is clear is that if you think on the past.
If you think especially in the twentieth century you also see how I would say political situations could influence the
field. when colonialism was something common. It had an impact on the field and the way.
People saw human evolution. for example for a long period Europe was seen as the center of human evolution.
Just because Europe was the center of the world
and so it was difficult to think that modern humans of today did not originate from Europe
and there are models in the first half of the twentieth century.
Where in which all the groups of living humans of today Africans Inuit Europeans or Asians
would originate from different sides of Europe.
You know now we find it funny but people. even ridiculous
but people did not think this way in the 1930 or forty. Where did they originate from the humans.
Well the modern humans originated in Africa.
And they expanded out of Africa
and even after you say that you don't really always measure what it means. practically it means that modern humans
ancestral to us to modern Europeans
when they arrived in the middle latitudes of Eurasia say fifty to forty thousand years ago they were probably black
guys you know and they changed their phenotype to adapt to the local conditions. OK.
Or I better say their phenotype changed to adapt to the local conditions so. And even today.
There are groups of scientists who are not very comfortable with the African origins of modern humans for example if you
look at the Chinese literature in the field it is very easy to detect that especially if you move back.
Not very far in time you see that there is a discomfort with African modern origins and.
There is a long tradition of seeing the human evolution in Asia as a distinct process of what has been going on in
other continents Europe or Africa
and so that the idea is that basically modern Chinese would originate in older hominins in China and.
then that could go back to homo erectus in China. And so in other words I have difficulty.
Difficulties thinking that this is not somehow stained by some form of nationalism.
So this idea that humans to start with the genius homo.
Originated in one place or another it's something which has been very popular but which is far from being demonstrated.
But now if you go today in South Africa or in Ethiopia or in Kenya or in Tanzania people will take your hand
and take you to the cradle of humankind somewhere so there are several cradles competing one with the other.
Well I don't know maybe there is no cradle maybe it's a much larger region.
Now for modern humans this notion that modern humans originated in a what has been called sometimes a Garden of Eden
by the way you see the connection with the Biblical mythology
Has been always very popular since this notion of African origin developed
and so this garden has been seen in different parts of sub-Saharan Africa where I'm not sure that the reality of the
data really confirms that
but the origin of modern humans has been always a topic where I would say political ideological nationalist issues have
been involved somehow. So before.
Before the Second World War there was this idea that modern humans originated in Europe.
And then during the Nazi regime there were even archaeologists that tried to prove that modern humans emerged in Germania.
You know and they Well they got some support from the Nazi regime to demonstrate that.
And today we see all these debates about where are the oldest modern humans it's still there.
And so people fight about different parts of Africa
or there are some people who think maybe it's in Asia that modern humans emerged
and again I think it's very difficult to think that you are not influenced by your direct environment because
first of all
you are more prone to advocate for origin in the places that you know where you have been studying different
sites and fossils and etc. In the end I think I see science as a Darwinian process. So there are many wrong ideas.
Even if sometimes they are very popular. It's not a very democratic activity
So the history of science is full of popular
ideas that have been proven to be wrong even if they were supported by a large number of people
but sometimes they have been falsified by minorities or even single individuals.
And so there is this sort of Darwinian process that basically allows this renewal of ideas.
One difficulty with paleoanthropology is that there is something that is often missing which is replication of the results
and I think a key aspect of modern science is replicability So if you if you produce any result it should be replicated
by others to be confirmed.
It's not always possible in archaeology
or in paleoanthropology. why because there are fields which are basically built up around sites.
So a place somewhere on earth and objects. and in general.
These sites or these objects they are controlled by individuals or groups or countries and so
when a good story has been elaborated around an object or a site and that this good story is somehow.
Very supportive for a individual or a group or a nation this individual this group
or this nation they are not going to be very willing to let other people come and check if it's true or not
So it takes a long time in the field of paleoanthropology sometimes to falsify
results. And
when it happens sometimes it's a bit sort of scandalous. We are just publishing a paper that's going to come out Friday.
I can speak about it because this recording
Will not be on air before but we have been asked by a museum to redate.
A fossil that has been studied by others
and this fossil has been published in major journals as an hybrid of Neanderthals and modern humans
and by redating this material we found that first of all it's very recent and it cannot be
a hybrid of Neanderthal and modern humans. B. that other fragments of humans that have been found around are not human.
In fact. And finally investigating the D.N.A. of these things we found out that it's certainly not.
a hybrid of Neanderthals and modern humans but a recent human probably of neolithic time.
But I predict that the publication of this paper is going to be not well taken.
Not just by the people who published the first study but I'm not sure that in general the field likes that. So.
Somehow it's always difficult to be the one who somehow creates some kind of little scandal about a nice story
that has been around for a while. You are always looking into the fossils into the ground but you also like to discover.
The orbit. The stars.
Oh by the way I've been interested in astronomy when I was I was kid al so I even still have a telescope a good one
In my basement. But. No I never considered making a profession of. Of something like that.
I've been interested in other things. First of all in my own field.
I think in another life I would like to do other things that I couldn't do in this one.
But outside of the scientific field I think I would have been very interested in another type of creation like
architecture or art. I'm very impressed by artists. I was a couple of days ago I was in Paris and I had a chance to.
Have dinner with. First of all to attend a presentation and have dinner with Anish Kapoor.
He's a very famous English Indian.
Sculptor and
and I'm always impressed by the way artists are able to explore the reality of things in a very different way than scientists
but. I have another question also Julian Huxley describes that through humans the universe is becoming conscious of itself
because of our brains. We're now creating a kind of mind of the universe. Can you elaborate a bit on that.
Well I think I tend to think on humans as a sort of collective brain and.
Probably what is most impressive about humans is that humans as individuals they are very sort of weak
and limited creatures. It is difficult to think on a human like a very dangerous creature for nature
or other animals but humans have been throughout their evolution able to create social groups
and then networks of social groups and networks that were always more extended and
and today we have this sort of almost collective intelligence of humans which is something that.
We do every day that to me.
Still is amazing is the fact that
when you miss some information you can sort of find it almost instantly in the collective brain of all humans of ours
you go on internet and.
I won't say the word but you you know type a certain name and you'll get all sorts of information about that.
And so this this capability to put in relation the intelligence and.
And memory of all humans is absolutely fascinating and goes much beyond information or.
Basically recording of anything.
It's also the capability that humans have to add expertise in a way that they can produce amazing results.
So somehow the main difference between us I mean when I say us I mean modern humans of today and
A Neanderthal
or an other hominin is that probably most of these people were able to do everything they needed to do to
make their life possible.
And of course for us it's completely different
and almost every single object that are around me not just objects many services
and functions in the modern societies are made possible by the addition of the expertise of many many people. So the
example which is often given is a cellular phone basically nobody would be able to build a cell phone
but by adding many many people who are able to conceive and to produce all the parts of a cellular phone
and the software and everything we have this amazing object.
So this notion that humans they represent a sort of network of memory and conscience.
Today is quite striking with especially the internet
and interconnection of many individuals is not a completely new idea somehow because you know if you moved back in the
nineteenth century. You had people who. Today it seems a bit strange but we may think of that.
Who separated in nature a vegetal reign a animal reign and a  human reign
and just yesterday I was reading a chapter of a book by De Quatrefages who is a very famous naturalist.
Just after the French Revolution and De Quatrefages developed in this book this notion of human reign.
And his argument is exactly this one is the notion that humans they have acquired.
Something that the rest of nature does not have is this self consciousness
And so especially if you see humans as a big network is the sort of self consciousness of the universe itself
somehow at least the living creatures on one planet. What I found a paradox is that and I'm a bit torn by that
somehow of course humans are absolutely unique.
In many aspects but in the meantime we know how they root in the living world
and we know that they root very close to apes like chimpanzees and bonobos
and so in other words I think this notion that of course the notion of human reign is kind of ridiculous because we
belong to the animal reign of course. it's not just that we belong to the animal world actually we are some kind of
bizarre apes very close from one species of other apes the chimpanzee
and a species which is further away from things like orangutans or gibbons or things like that.
So we tend to develop this notion of exceptionalism of.
Of humans but to some extent it's true of course with living humans with modern humans
and I mentioned many aspects that make them absolutely unique in the history of life.
In the meantime I think we have to be careful not to project
or extend this notion of exceptionalism into the past because if we move into the past.
Hominins that lived a hundred, two hundred, five hundred thousand years ago.
I think they were just like another species of mammals on earth and they are something a bit unusual.
Carnivorous predatory apes able to run after animals and catch them eat them. But in terms of.
Simply in terms of numbers there was nothing remarkable nothing really visible in the landscape I would say.
And if you think for example on the competition between humans and carnivores
There are places on earth where obviously humans sort of.
Succeeded in this competition but there are other places where it's not so obvious for a long time
and so for example we think that the development of human groups. Say before half a million year ago in Europe.
Was probably somehow limited by the reach and dangerous variety
of large carnivores existing in this part of the planet and so
it took us some time to take over the situation so.
Again I think we should refrain ourselves from projecting in the past.
What humans are today or how we want to see us today.
I think this is a main problem. it has been always a problem in paleoanthropology. Somehow
Even people working on hominins living two million years ago or more wanted to see them like a version
A little bit more primitive of modern humans but running around in the savanna having villages
and meeting every night to tell stories to each other which I think it's a fantasy.
Last question you are in the art. Our series is in archetypes. Every episode is an archetype. You are in The Conqueror.
Does that fit well? Well you mean. A conqueror. I can interpret that two ways. One way is
As an individual and another way is regarding my topic of research. So as an individual.
I have been always a rather ambitious person I think
and I my first years on earth were very challenging in many ways and I could not have survived I had a difficult start.
And I was poor.
And so I was a immigrant I was a refugee
and I had these kind of I think retrospectively I can see that I had this sort of rage of.
You know managing doing well in life and being successful in reaching my goals and.
Even from a material point of view to be you know on the safe side I would say. So yeah a conqueror my mother would
Like that probably. if she would hear that. Now if you think of my topic my main topic of interest.
Certainly you can see the evolution of humans as a sort of epics. Epic Story of a conquest of the planet by a species.
I try to keep a cool brain somehow about that because this is something you find a lot in the literature
in the also in the popular literature the T.V.
Documentaries in films and I think it's a sort of retrospective way we have to tell the story.
And it meets this this storytelling which is so popular about the mythology of our
Species the mythology of our human societies and modern societies. I think somehow humans have been driven into these.
Ecological niche. First completely by chance I would say and the fact is that we are lucky to be humans and not to be.
Endangered species on Earth but.
We have to remember that many other hominins humans existed on earth and they are not here anymore.
And so that should maybe give us a certain level of modesty
or maybe you know it's a sort of warning that we have to be careful because species are mortal
And evolution is mostly about extinction.
So it's nice that we have this level of consciousness that allows us to speak about it and to analyze a lot of things
but so let's be wise somehow. So we have been conquerors by accident but let's be wise men now.